[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
(SINGING) Maybe this
time I'll be lucky.
Maybe this time he'll stay.
Maybe this time for the first
time love won't hurry away.
He will hold me fast.
I'll be home at last.
Not a loser.
Anymore.
Like the last time
and the time before.
Everybody loves a winner
so nobody loved me.
I call singing my
first language.
Our currency is being open
and being open and available
to our emotions.
If you're closed
off as a person,
how are you going
to be a performer,
to get out there and show love,
or show agony, or show despair?
(SINGING) Do what I
want without listening.
Listen.
Make sure I'm listening to the
person I'm up there on stage
with, because if
you're truly listening,
then that'll force you
to be in the moment.
(SINGING) You would
die without me.
I pray not to let me go.
Yes, the strong gets more,
while the weak ones fail.
Empty pockets don't ever
make the grade Mama may have,
Papa may have, but
God bless the child.
Less got his own.
'Cause God is all.
Evolution is very important
to me as an artist.
Usually if I'm scared of
it I know I have to do it.
I will be a better
actress, a better artist--
doesn't necessarily mean
that I will succeed,
but will I have
grown as a result?
(SINGING) From this
minute I'm telling you.
I keep this vow.
Oh, my Porgy.
Oh, my Bessy.
You is my woman now.
[APPLAUSE]